Using the search tree for practical purposes, we may have already gained some efficiency.
But now the question is, does it really affect the running time of the algorithm when we use
O notation and worst-case running time?
Or is it just something that gives us some constant factor saving some practice?
It's hard to tell right now because this tree as we've considered it is highly dependent
on the structure of the graph that we're analyzing and we need to think a little bit more about this.
One interesting thing to consider is the following:
There were only two cases when we stopped further exploration in this tree here.
One case was that we had found a valid vertex cover.
The other one was when we considered an edge that could not be covered any more.
Actually doing it this way is not the smartest possible way because for vertex cover
we already know one thing.
If you look at an edge such as this one here, then this edge here has two endpoints
and now we want to assign these endpoints to be in the vertex cover or to not be in the vertex cover.
So far we have looked at the vertices individually,
but we could also look at both vertices at the same time so not go into two different possibilities
but actually go in three different possibilities.
There's three cases that makes sense here of assigning the vertices
to be on the vertex cover or not.
So we know this edge needs to be covered somehow and there's actually just
three different possibilities of doing that.
One is you take this endpoint here into the vertex cover.
The other one is you take this vertex here into the vertex cover.
Or of course you can also take both.
But you can ignore the case where you would put none of the two endpoints into the vertex cover
because then you already know that your solution doesn't make sense.
This of course also covers other edges as well and now our algorithm can actually very quickly
come to a solution because when we look at this edge here, there's only one possible choice
that remains and that is taking this vertex here into the vertex cover.
All edges are covered. We have a solution of size 2.
So now let's do a worst-case analysis and say that this is the edge that the algorithm considers next.
In all of the three cases, the edge is uncovered so it again goes into three possibilities here,
three possibilities here, and three possibilities here.
Of course if we had been lucky and had chosen this edge here,
the algorithm would have had a much easier choice and actually we're later going to look at
such optimizations for the algorithm and again we're going to branch into the three cases that
makes sense for that edge so this one here would make sense for that edge
but of course it leads to an invalid solution.
This one here is actually the best possible solution.
And this one here is also a solution but it's a larger one,
and we're going to do the same thing over here.
Now, what you might be thinking is, "Oh no! Now we're trying nine assignments."
But the good thing is that, we can now do a worst-case analysis of this.